when the call went out last year for
venues to host a backlog of court cases
the team at peterborough cathedral was
one of the first to respond there's the
old ad is that justice delayed
is justice tonight and we hope glad to
be able to help we've had some fraud
cases here we sometimes see journalists
outside when there's a really salacious
case
with a few new accessories this 800 year
old room can accommodate a socially
distanced judge and jury
this cathedral and dozens of churches
hotels and theaters offered themselves
up as nightingale courts to hear cases
during the pandemic and many are still
going because covid and a buildup of
spending cuts have left victims waiting
years for justice
lisa not her real name worked up the
courage to report a sex offense which
happened when she was a child it was
three years and several cancelled
hearings before the perpetrator was
jailed this year at one point i actually
wrote a letter to the judge to say
actually i feel like i'm in prison that
you know the trial keeps getting getting
cancelled i felt like i was serving a
prison sentence
what has been the impact on your life of
that long wait
devastated to be honest with you i
haven't been able to do my job for
quite long periods of time
um
it has destroyed my personal life
it has just yeah you know i was gonna
move house back in december that hasn't
happened and i had plans to adopt that
hasn't happened everything has been on
hold
um because i didn't want this man to be
able to do what he did to me to somebody
else
today a new super courtroom opens in
loughborough to accommodate cases with
up to 12 defendants in the dock we put
lisa's case to the justice secretary
dominic raab who said the new court
would free up more space to get through
other serious cases like hers
well i totally understand that on top of
the appalling crime that they've
suffered they've got the extra anguish
and ordeal of this weight in limbo which
is exactly why we're pushing a billion
pounds across the court system to get
the wheels of justice whirring back uh
like normal now the treasury gave you
some more money they expected the
backlog to be 53 000 in three years time
so at that rate we're looking at seven
or eight years to get the backlog down
is that an acceptable time scale well
look we're going to go as fast as we can
we've got a billion pounds across the
whole court system we've got to use
technology seven or eight years is is
what it could be realistically i can't
tell you with any precision exactly when
we'll get back to pre-pandemic levels
but i'm confident that within six to
twelve months at the very latest we will
start getting the backlog coming down
for those in the system many of those on
the long road to getting justice feel
they are the ones on trial tamarico and
sky news